[Music]
today we're going to talk about how we
are optimizing our asari team's
effectiveness in enabling our
engineering teams to deliver
applications in a reliable stable
performant and providing digital
experience that matches our first
in-class journalism agenda is to go over
some of the challenges that we have in
our environment and talk about how we
work as a team and then Vanessa will
unpack some of the ways how we're
building our personal maturity across
the teams using product mindset and then
I'll walk you into an engagement model
that we use to work with the engineering
teams and develop tooling or lessons
that could be applied across the arc and
then we'll also take you to some of the
ways that we evangelize or sre practices
that our men should drive the culture
change that you'd need when you have
your applications running in the cloud
firstly the challenges in 2018 we
transform our infrastructure we shut
down our data centers and migrated to
the cloud this transformation was not
just about the migration but the tooling
that we used to have on the culture we
had around how we manage our
infrastructure we the opted
containerization and put in tools that
would enable us to build in a cloud
native way I'll talk more into that
tooling but during that time we built
the tooling that enabled our engineers
basically to deliver applications faster
and the migration was successful on our
own time this all sounds like happily
ever after but right off of migration we
realize
really sorry work has just begun let's
take a look at one of our business
workflow that we have that spans across
the team's the workflow is basically a
newsroom trying to publish an article
and it shows up on our front end
applications the editor would compile
the article in our content management
system hit published the article lands
on our publishing pipeline and the
content API is formats these contents
into a way that is consumable by all the
front end apps at a high level this is a
simple workflow but during the migration
what we did was we enable the teams by
providing autonomy or their cloud
infrastructure by giving them full
control of their infrastructure in their
GCP projects so if you were to look at
the content management system here is
made of micro services but the team that
manages that system owns end to end of
all the micro services and deploy in
their own GCB project and so are the
other systems in this workflow the
challenge here is our user experience
depends on all these systems that we are
seeing here we did not have an
aggregated view of how we measure our
user experience when teams are working
in their own GCB projects i'm working
with their own infrastructure in a way
that they're missing out on how their
system is impacting a wider user
experience from an engineering
standpoint there are two users here one
the news room that's trying to publish
an article and so the readers are
consuming so we had to
we think and we saw in need for building
those aggregated views of measuring how
our user experience gets impacted when
this systems are making changes so
initially I spoke about the tooling that
we build at the name of the migration is
basically what we did was we adapted to
the cloud native tools we have
consistency ICD withdrawn and we started
using kubernetes and ask Google to
manage our kubernetes
which is Jiki we do plan your x comm on
gke a year ago and we have prometheus
for understanding how the systems
perform we also have fastly well self
serviceable distributed edge caching
tool that is basically available for any
front-end engineering team to put their
application out and we also have
transformed from being this you know
data center based infrastructure to
infrastructure as code which terraform
and we also have tooling to support
applications needs like secrets
management with Walt a PKI management
with Walt so the tooling is already
there but what we are missing is a
component that you don't see on the
slide that is the application so we have
the tooling but what we need is
operational maturity on the teams to use
these tools in a way that they can build
applications that match this allows that
master user experience that is is is
required from them right so having that
operational maturity alongside of this
great tools is a need that we have seen
so what is the lay of the land at the
New York Times is we have 400 less
applications and we have 40 plus teams
managing 400 applications and these
applications range from a cloud native
user facing apps to enterprise apps that
are built by third party but the teams
deploy for our internal use so there's a
wide variety of these apps with those
white variety they're wide variety of
needs for these apps to be in the cloud
that reflects in the teams you like the
teams have different experience and
skills especially around asari skills
that they would need to manage the type
of depending on the type of the app
however what is consistent is after the
migration we're asking the teams to
manage their own infrastructure that is
consistent regardless of what type of
app they use or build so what we saw is
we as a team had to work with these
teams engage with them and build skills
on their teams that would enable them
regardless of what type of app they're
managing would be successful in meeting
their solos so in the data center world
we had a centralized ops team so we came
from that was in the cloud and this
centralized ops team was managing
infrastructure for the teams so that is
a culture change that we've gone through
in the last one and half year but
however the processes that we have they
still reflect the design center model
and we still continue to use them which
is more like trying to fit a square peg
in a round hole I'll give you an example
or biggest example that I can think of
when it comes to managing systems in the
data center
our priority one management or priority
one defect management process where it
works really well if we apply to single
team because that's what it is built for
but when an outage spans across multiple
teams and it becomes really hard the
teams try to figure out the problem and
then pass that problem to other teams
figuring out like this is not the cause
of we have and it goes to the other team
and goes to another team until finally a
resolution is arrived so if you've seen
that process fail then we have
distributed engineering teams managing
their own infrastructure and we had to
rethink the way how we could managing
our priority one defects so that's just
an example so we had to rethink about
the processes that we have from the data
center how did we address all these
problems you can guess it yes through SI
program but how did we do it it's
outside of it what we do for most of our
teams when we we talk about how we form
the team there's always a back story and
who is an asari is an interesting
conversation that I often hear but our
team is pretty much what the book
prescribes we went by the book we build
tooling and automation to help our
engineering teams to manage their
production systems may be incident
management may be tracking their s ellos
the most important thing that we do is
engage with the engineering teams you
engage to build the operational maturity
on the teams it could be on a specific
problem or it could be a tooling app
that might be useful for other
engineering teams
or it could just be anything that
involves building reliability into the
systems that's what we engage on a
one-on-one basis for we also provide
documentation on process as a way to
guide these teams to use our tooling to
eat to have analyzed the asari practices
and we go one step further and provide
workshops workshops around how to be an
incident commander workshops are on how
do you manage your incidents so that's
the process and guidance we provide so
now you've seen the challenges you've
seen what we do as a team now my
colleague Vanessa will talk about how
the program works to build that
operational edge David I've been talking
about thanks for Sean
it's a product management mindset so
Prashant mentioned we had a central team
that controlled all of the
infrastructure decisions for New York
Times applications so shifting to GCP
and making that decision to have now
application development teams manage
their own infrastructure I required a
shift in our thinking our team delivery
engineering with the asari function was
formed not to control the infrastructure
because other app teams control their
own infrastructure we sought to empower
these teams so therefore we had a shift
our way of thinking as well I know you
get a project manager for the first time
at a tech conference you're going to
hear the agile manifesto but that was a
source of inspiration for how we decided
to operationalize sre individuals and
interactions over processes and tools
and it's not to say that the tooling and
processes and all the cool things that
you see today and all the great things
that we do I mean they're vital to
making change
but what we're talking about is when you
are aiming that teams have to be
operationally mature which means they're
going to be managing essary practices on
their own that's a culture change and
that starts with people so product
management thinking it starts with
viewing our internal teams as customers
and what that means is you have to
incentivize people using teams using
your tooling teams listening to your
guidance teams using and applying your
processes I'm gonna be honest like I
this sometimes is the hardest part of my
job it would be a lot easier in the
short term if we just require teams to
use our tools but that comes up that
risk because what it means if we don't
do this we risk not being able to
provide tooling that speeds up
development that improves a velocity
that helps teams be lip deliver a
reliable and user experience so we
ourselves we are incentivized to
constantly seek that feedback and get
that data to drive our decision-making
process our team formed in March 2016
and we call that and identified a focus
of how we are going to collect this
feedback and data was gonna be around
how teams perceived us why do we need to
measure perception our old
infrastructure and systems teams they
were perceived as blockers and
bottlenecks because they had to control
everything as part of the mission and
the way we were structured and so we
wanted to change that perception as well
we wanted team we wanted to build trust
with teams to feel that they can rely on
us on our tooling and our best practices
so the feedback process it's evolved
we've been running the process for a
couple years and it's evolved a bit but
we've come up with a really stable
process and it's very much modeled from
what you might see from front-end design
and the process runs about twice a year
and the process it builds
user empathy as well as the ability to
measure patterns over time we always aim
for balanced representation because
we're building tools for all of the
times and when I say balanced
representation it's not just hearing
from teams but recently we've also been
aiming to make sure the non engineers
and the team understand the value we
provide because a lot of times if though
it's those folks that actually control
and govern the roadmap the bow and then
of course it has to help us plan it has
to be actionable and it's not to say
that this is the only source of input
into our roadmap there's always top-down
efforts that have to be done you know
particularly in the security and
compliance arena but this is a major
input that fuels what we do and where
our focus will be our feedback it's into
the way we collect feedback it's two
parts it's a survey and it's qualitative
interviews the survey itself is very
much designed with user empathy in mind
it's very short it's mostly quantitative
questions again we want to make it easy
for people if you make something easy in
terms of getting feedback you're gonna
get more feedback and it's obvious right
but the fact of the matter is sometimes
people want to give a lot of information
but you can't substitute a survey with a
converse late for conversation so what
we do and this is one of my favorite
questions is our very first question let
me see if I use the pointer is we say we
value your feedback if you want to talk
with us leave your name here and we'll
reach out and have a conversation with
you and we handle that as part of the
qualitative interview process
now the process actually started with
just a few managers on the team doing
these interviews but we decided to
actually open this whole process up so
that anyone in our team any engineer can
sign up to interview someone or even
scribe for an interview this has
delivered benefits not just in terms of
us being able to get better reach in
getting more feedback it also builds a
lot more empathy
when you have a conversation with people
they feel like they're being hurt but it
also motivates our engineers I mean how
often an intern a tooling team do you
actually get to do a practice like this
and this is a catalyst also because it
let us create much better guidelines and
templates and how we actually create
qualitative interviews and so why having
this we're able to collect all this
information in a consistent way we take
these results and we synthesize them as
a team to make sure that we have a
correct view in our findings this means
if you're in test automation or even if
you're in a sari you are part of this
process and you're represented and then
we carve out a whole week where we dive
into and we call it the team brainstorm
week and this is when we go through all
the pain points that people went through
what are things that we're doing that we
should actually continue or do more of
and what are the opportunities that we
need to explore as part of our roadmap
and then of course we share these
results out it's very important I want
to emphasize this because sometimes
there's this tendency to collect this
information and it could be really hard
it's hard to sometimes say yeah we
really didn't do really great at it but
it's more important to say we recognize
this and this is what we're doing about
it
or what we even heard from the feedback
is hey I get it if you can't do
everything because there's just so much
to do but at least can you tell me that
you're hearing it and understand and
explain what is the other part I see so
Madonna you get it so we share this
feedback for the coming quarters and
then we say okay here are potential
projects but it's also a filter in terms
of who are teams that we should be
partnering with to work out these
complex problems and that is what Rochon
is going to talk about in the engagement
model thank you
engagements are opportunities for your
team to work with other engineering
teams on a one-on-one basis and focus on
maximizing the results of why you are
engaging with right the idea here is to
generate automation or
learning that could be applied across
the art and we work with the engineering
teams and we focus on maximizing the
results by following our engagement
model so if you are an SRE engineering
manager it's very important to define
who as an asari is and what his role is
or her role is and manage communications
and collaborations with across the team
to build that operational maturity but
for that you have to proactively define
all of that in your engagement model you
may ask why would we need an engagement
model to wait yeah when we did not have
an engagement model we were still
working with teams and engaging with
them however the issue there was we
always had misaligned priorities and we
were in a situation in one of our
engagements with whether we focus on
capacity planning or whether we want to
build a tooling gap that is like a you
know Bluegreen deployments on our
kubernetes tooling that we provide to
our engineering teams so not just the
priority alignment but when we were
dealing with the culture change when
there was an ops team and we as a sorry
team were working on the engineering
team they often looked at as well as ops
engineers who could do this one-off
scripting for them that but that's not
necessary is we clearly define that in
our engagement model and put it in front
of our engineering teams and our model
is based off of shared goals if you read
the asahi workbook there's a whole
chapter on how you should engage with
your engineering teams and I've
contributed the model in detail on
chapter 18 but at a high level its basis
of shared goals shared goals are
as a team that is building operational
maturity on other teams my goal is to
build something that can be applied
across the arc not just with them so we
use our goals and we use engineering
teams goals align them and call that as
the scope of an engagement once the
shared goals are set the engineers will
sprint on the milestones and the
managers will keep the communication and
feedback loop live until the end of the
communication and we measure the impact
by performing operational maturity
assessments appointing estimates of
operational maturity before we begin the
engagement and after the engagement is
done and we derive the metrics to
compare what the engagement results are
and we publish them I'll watch it
through one of the example as we've seen
we had this challenge of having shared
views of reliability across multiple
teams so that we could capture the user
experience and monitor our SLO s--
shared view of reliability and my son
zero we call it milestone zero because
at the time we did not really know what
shared view of reliability meant and how
would we build that tooling that could
be applied across or arc so the
milestone zero is to derive that
requirements and plan further rollout
this is a unique engagement because what
we did was we approached our Google Tam
and customer engineers and put out our
problems and they referred to Google
series so we worked alongside of Google
series they were like partners with our
team they were participating in regular
check-ins to review what as
those really meant while we were working
with a frameworks team that had multiple
apps built on that framework and build a
tool that could capture these SL O's in
a single pane of glass I'm not able to
show the exact framework SL O's here but
this is our drone SL O's built on the
same tool but it says it's a place where
anyone can see s ellos for all the apps
for that framework it's this example of
like how you could involve Google series
alongside and get the benefit of them
drive your goal
Google's here is even did a workshop for
non-technical participants in that
engagement and explain what SLO this
really meant because it's really hard to
get as a loss right if you're doing it
the first time and that was our first
time ever to have standard as a lost
rolled out today we have this tool and
we are working on rolling that out so
our engagements are not just like
tooling apps milling operational
maturity we also work drive special
events at the New York Times and Vanessa
will talk about one such special event
this is such an exciting time to be at
the New York Times its events and
elections like this that make me
particularly proud to be part of the
organization and elections are always
special event but this year it's been
kind of different the political climate
itself plus the attention to our site
it's it's just been unprecedented and
also since 2016 our digital
subscriptions have doubled we were
expecting traffic for a midterm like
never before
we formed a cross-functional project and
the mission was that New York Times
would remain to be a key destination for
reliable up-to-date election results it
was a cross team effort and we wanted to
ensure that our news and interactive
content was stable performant always
up-to-date and as our newsroom intends
to for our users and we also aim to
minimize issues in case they did come up
and that we would also have a minimum
response and measures in place to
resolve them quickly I want you to
remember this was our first ever event
like this on GCP usually the scope for
elections it typically focuses on you
know there are interactive and are
publishing content up through what we
kind of call the cars stack of how it
looks to the end-user on the site but uh
traditionally we always just take down
the paywall
because it was just too complex and just
too costly to be able to do that for an
event but now being able to leverage
GK's auto leveraging an auto scaling and
the team's investment in essary is a
discipline as well as all the work they
done with test automation it let them
have you know better Basics in place
with regards to like performance metrics
essentially for the first time our
business and marketing team was able to
take advantage of this surge in traffic
as a business opportunity we decided to
leave the pay well up as a tactic to
gain user registrations on our site so
the
later we could reach out to those users
to see if they would be interested in
becoming subscribers so this increased
the scope and we were looking at at
least over 30 teams that we needed to
assemble around readiness and this
involved a lot we were focused very much
on the technical readiness of it but it
also did involve coordination with
newsroom marketing business advertising
so how did we assemble this effort I
remember being at next about a couple
years ago and there's a really great
talk I think GCP podcast also does an
episode on it and it's home depot is
with google's cre team and they're
talking about the preparation for Home
Depot's first Black Friday on GCP both
companies partner together they made an
upfront commitment to roll out tooling
and best practices and that Google would
be in the room with the Home Depot all
throughout Black Friday
Home Depot success was Google's success
any failure on Home Depot site was also
be shared with Google it was a shared
fate and so when I was asked to be one
of the project managers our project
owner being outside delivery engineering
as well as the other election leads on
it
we're wondering how do we how do we
start what kind of work do we do and I
immediately thought back to that shared
fate example we were able to partner
with our delivery engineering essary
team to collaborate them and start
mapping out the work that we needed to
get all these teams ready for elections
this work started with doing a series of
architectural reviews we pulled
representatives from all these teams in
one big room and they went over there in
their architecture questions like what
fail overs did they have in place and
our s3 team was able to identify quick
resiliency wins that they could work on
Prashant mentioned a lot of our
challenges with incident management
because teams were still reliant on us
you know a central systems
infrastructure team to handle a lot of
their p1 incidents but that just
wouldn't work during midterms our team
had as prep had started building up
training materials around incident
management what to do how people should
actually be managing an incident these
are practices actually inspired by
emergency response today and we train
over a hundred people in the technology
and news room how to respond in case
there was a production incident what we
also refer to as a p1 and of course we
partnered with our Google tamps they let
us know on day one of this project that
they would be with us on-site and we
figured out and documented what are all
the processes that we needed to do and
also what resources would be available
so if something happened they would be
there for us throughout the duration of
the projects we conducted stress tests
so increasing load on the systems to
find out where the vulnerabilities were
not only did this help us technically
but so after each test we would conduct
the learning review or blameless
post-mortem and we would do go through
the timeline and then discuss where did
we get lucky where did things go right
where did things not go wrong and we
didn't just talk about it from a
technical level this also helped guide
like just even logistics you know which
teams how to sit next to each other
because you can't put 30 teams in a war
room but that also just gauged what was
the optimum way that we needed to work
and communicate to make sure we were
successful on midterms so here is us
during elections see if you can find
Conejo and find prashanth and he's there
with our Google rep and we're talking
with our interactive news team but I
could show more pictures but let's go
through the results now I can't go
through particular details with traffic
and subscription but yes it was record
traffic for midterms you can see
particularly one zoom shot is the
registration pay wall they started you
can see per for can anyone guess the
peak when midterms happen about 40 times
its traffic and then you could even
follow up with the news bump in the
morning news cycle
this allowed significant registration
growth and of course incidents occurred
we did have production incidents but it
was actually really small and because we
had put all this preparation in to
having responses in police and failover
plans in place we had very minimal user
impact the resolution was rapid and
almost instant in terms of in terms of
the end-user experience so it's
important to celebrate events like this
you know we talked about our mindset we
talked about how we work internally how
we partner engagement with teams but how
do we evangelize ourselves across our
organization I've worked on a lot of fun
and teams and in advertising and it's
kind of straightforward to explain your
success you could just point to a fun
and feature you could point to a revenue
impact but it's our type of work is it's
hard to explain to people in the
business that don't do what we do I
often say we're kind of like stage crew
you know you don't realize our success
until things actually break and then
it's yeah um so we were I'm also very
inspired from feedback that we got
through earlier feedback surveys and
someone who specifically said you know
okay I do all this work with your team
and this has helped me but I don't we
don't really get to talk about it this
much we should just share more of these
stories so inspired with that we decided
to kick off a project within our team we
held york times first-ever internal tech
conference now delivering engineering
internally we abbreviate ourselves to DV
and we thought we'd do a fun little
wordplay on DevOps day so we did DV ops
day our CFP called out you know we want
to know what's working what's not
working even from since our cloud
migrations in q2 and we wanted teams to
share their best practices where
operational support testing tooling and
automation it was very important that we
reached out to the teams first because
again we want to empower other teams we
didn't want to just be us talking and it
wasn't we had 13 talks that included
presentations and demos with topics like
production deployments with App Engine
using hash leak or vault for GCP service
list solutions 75% of these speakers
were outside of our team and most of
these speakers were first-time speakers
or it was a really long time before they
spoke we also had in addition to
presentations and topics we had a
workshop on how to facilitate learning
reviews and we also held a panel
comprised of teams that went through
production readiness reviews to talk
about what their experiences were like
and working with our team
the majority of volunteers that day were
also outside our team which was also
very impactful to kind of just get even
the not anybody involved and it was a
pretty snowy day we held the conference
on January late January and if anyone's
in from New York you know it's snows and
the commuting is not it was that great
but we actually had over a hundred
people sign up that day and that doesn't
think that count doesn't include all the
people who join remotely one snippet
from our panel this was from an audience
member who was specifically talking
about the panel production readiness for
reviews how powerful it was and I think
the other takeaway from this is that
this person can refer to it of about
your customers for us that was already a
big win so going forward we're aiming to
have more of these events intact if
anything the feedback was overwhelmingly
we want more of these events we want to
share more of these stories I remember
even remembering prashanth and I on an
elevator ride down when we were working
on this presentation there's a developer
who ran into something elevator eCos you
know my goal next year is to present at
the next day the ops day so I'm going to
hand off to Rashad now who's going to
talk more about how we're looking
forward by no means we have covered all
the challenges that we have and the work
that we saw post migration looking at
2019 and beyond
sorry looks like this is like missing
but we've been looking to like build
operational maturity and the teams
continue doing our engagements with the
teams to build tooling and we'll
stability into our applications but a
quick summary tools can't reduce soil
but a saris can impact by partnering
with teams and building operational
maturity so think about engaging on
teams that are having specific problems
that could be you know replicated
elsewhere easily so you want to tackle
those through your engagements and apply
product management mindset to build that
operational maturity because building
operations maturity is a culture change
treat your engineering teams as your
customers ask feedback on a regular
cadence and source that back in as your
requirements for your tooling or
guidance and define an engagement model
that is goal-oriented and works for your
team because as I mentioned like
engaging with your teams is a key for
your success leverage your champs
customer engineers they have insight
into what works and what doesn't because
they have more experience tapping into
the resources from Google and they and
working with Google CRE for us had
turned out into a really great
experience because we were able to like
get validation from someone outside of
the company to look at the tooling and
the SLO xavi were building and
evangelize irizarry practices to steer
up that culture change and not but not
least celebrate your successes we as a
company are growing and my team is going
please take a look at our job site we're
looking for talented engineers
I know I can see a lot here and check
out our blocks open that and my time
sarcomere we talk about what we do
[Music]